the hard problem of Consciousness is the
problem of how physical processes could
ever give rise to subjective experiences
how do neuronal firings in our brain
lead to our inner lives imagine watching
a sunset you experience warm colors the
sense of awe perhaps a feeling of
Serenity but how do these subjective
experiences arise from Mere neural
activity consider the famous thought
experiment of Mary someone who's never
seen color herself when she finally does
see color she gains new knowledge the
experience of color how can this
experiential knowledge be accounted for
in a purely physical description of the
world there's also the related binding
problem which deals with how our brain
integrates information from different
senses into a unified conscious
experience lastly what are the
implications of the hard problem for the
Free Will debate if we can't fully
understand the emergence of
Consciousness from physical processes
can we truly claim that our actions are
the result of conscious intentions we
talked about the hard problem with David
Chalmer subscribe to get notified